In the call to what does not contradict evil, what do you mean by
theology? What do you mean by
theology? I've seen that those who object to it
often talk, for example, about
rational proofs for the existence of God. This isn't
theology, no, it's not theology. These are rational proofs,
not theology that prioritizes reason over religious law. Theology that glorifies reason,
glorifies reason
even if it contradicts religious law.
This is the theology that scholars talk about,
or they talk about the unseen without religious texts.
But if it's just rational reasoning, and that's all there is to it, then
this is what is prioritizing reason over religious law,
prioritizing reason over evil, according to the Ash'arites, Mu'tazilites, and Maturidites.